one thing's for sure the Farrelly
Brothers the ones that wrote this movie
they're probably married and they're
probably miserable Hall Pass so we saw
the trailer the Hall Pass we thought
okay movie that shows that guys are pigs
even when they're married they want a
bank chick so their lives go okay you
have a week go bang chicks reverse
psychology says now that they can
they're not gonna do it you know but all
in all I just wanted the movie to be
funny was it funny there was some funny
stuff in it like for the first half
though it was a bit boring
maybe it's because you saw the entire
first half of the movie in the trailer
you know Owen Wilson and the guy that
reminds me of Ed Helms and all their
friends go to Applebee's and they're so
out of the game they can't pick up any
chick so the thing is when you meet Owen
Wilson you're like the guy is actually
quite douchey I'm just saying he's
unlikable II tweets jenna fischer like
[ __ ] jenna fischer on the other hand
dresses so plain she dresses like pam
from the office like episode 1 then of
course when she gives him a hall pass
she dresses all hot you know like normal
shirts you know the t-shirts that are
like tight t-shirts but like why
couldn't she dress like that when they
could you know however it is quite
possible that to relate to this movie
you have to be married and miserably so
i'm neither you see this single happy
but i'm gonna say yeah we all look at
chicks so these guys were like
excessively doing it if i were married
to a chick that checked out guys the way
these guys check out chicks i'd be like
you're a dick kill hall pass get to get
out it's like when the movie was really
trying to be funny like cop car chases
and mayhem and anarchy wasn't that funny
but i had these really simple moments
like these one thing that would happen
hilarious i died laughing so the
smallest things made this movie funny
but the rows have a lot of missed
opportunities like this guy is like
hanging on to this car and he's busting
out the windshield with this crowbar no
one made a terminator to reference it
would have been hilarious when you see a
guy hanging on the back of a car and
busting out the windshield with a
crowbar you make a terminator to
reference this is one of the graphs but
it got me in the end douchey unrelatable
dudes the chicks were hypocritical
though they annoyed me too so the
relationships just annoy me the people
in the relationships annoy me I mean it
was kind of funny seeing them out of the
game they've been out of the game for
like 20 years so they don't know how to
hit on chicks that's pretty funny but if
I wanted to see that I'd just go hit on
chicks just kidding I'm single so like
you know can successfully hit on chicks
that's why the blonde Australian girl
though the girl in the trailer she was
also in the last season of scrubs you
know the crappy season she's in it she
oh my she's hot just saying she's not my
wife yeah was Natalie Portman then Anne
Hathaway
now this chick yeah I guess guys are
fickle in the end you chuckle but there
are funnier movies out there that make
fun of relationships so I'd say it's
okay but you're not gonna remember it in
t-minus 15 minutes I relate more to the
hangover than I do this movie maybe
that's it except for the black and now
part in Vegas never black out in Vegas
remember it oh it's awesome but if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]